- Your daughter just
went to college, right?
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Are you stressed about that?
My daughter's seven and
I'm already freaking out.
- Stressed is not even the word.
- [Kelly] 'Cause their on their own.
- It's the only time I've
ever regretted children.
Having them.
- I have sons, so I feel
like it'll be less stressful.
- [Kelly] Oh, no, you're
gonna get so many calls.
- [Brooke] You think that-
- Oh, God. I feel like all I
have to worry about is like,
don't hit your head right now.
- [Kelly] 'Cause you send
them out there and you hope
you've done your best and I'm
just freaking out about it.
And it's so far away.
- The driving away from them-
- [Kelly] (whispers
quietly) You're leaving.
- In college, it was like
I had been just gut punched
and I couldn't, well, I was just,
I choke sobbed, that like,
ugly crying in the car.
My husband was so funny, he
said, okay so, when we go home,
would you rather cry in the car
or would you rather cry in a plane?
And I was like, I need a car.
I can't be on a public
plane and be with people.
- [Kelly] Sobbing.
- Sobbing. They'll think
something's wrong with me.
So, yeah, and then you see them thriving,
and they don't have time for you anymore.
And you're just like,
(faux crying) I'm so
happy you're so happy.
- [Kelly] (faux crying) I'm so
happy you're so independent.
- [Brooke] (faux crying) How dare you.
I mean, I was never that independent.
You know, I mean, I was
sick, missing my mom.
And so the fact that she,
in a way I have envy -
- [Kelly] I have karma coming
my way, I was so independent.
My kids are both gonna never call me.
- [Brooke] No.
- [Kelly] I was so
independent and I love that.
You love that you raised
independent little beings-
- [Kirsten] Healthier, really.
- But at the same time,
you're like, need me a little.
- And they do. Then you'll
get the crying phone call.
Or the, you know, and then
you're sort of like, oh well,
okay, they still need me.
But you don't want them
unhappy, but she's thriving.
- [Kelly] That's exciting.
- Yeah, and it's just, it's one of those-
- Like her whole world is before her.
That's exciting as a mom, yeah.
- Yeah, and she's doing
all these activities,
and she's playing intermural sports,
and she's trying out for the musical.
So it's really, it's, but I will say
I never thought it would
be that hard to just-
- [Kelly] I know it's gonna be hard.
- It's so hard to be in
the house without them.
- I just said my daughter
seven, she's nowhere near this
and I'm already freaking out about it.
because it's just so weird
when you have them around
and it's your every day and then-
- And now I'm just with the
15 year old, which is a joy.
- [Kirsten] Oh gosh.
(everyone laughs)
- [Kelly] Every second.
- 15 is such an easy age for
girls, and their mothers.
- [Kirsten] Especially in Los Angeles.
- [Brooke] Oh we get along and-
- Instagram and all that.
- [Kelly] Oh my God,
there's so much to look forward to for me.
So wait, so let's talk about the positive.
Your new movie, your new
Netflix movie, is called
- [Kelly And Brooke] A
Castle for Christmas.
- [Kelly] A Castle for Christmas,
which is what I want for Christmas.
- It's a good thing to
want and they're for sale
all over the place.
- [Kelly] They are, you
a Zillow porn person?
- Love it.
- [Kelly] We probably
can't say that on here,
but I literally, I'm in love with Zillow.
I call it Zillow porn.
There are castles and chateaus,
it's the craziest thing,
they'll probably edit this out,
but you can look them
up and they're for sale.
- I know, and what's interesting,
so we were in Scotland
smack in the middle of COVID.
And we were in a bubble.
So we were just with these people
and we all lived sort of in the same place
but they had me in a house, a first house.
And then, I ended up moving
to the carriage house
of a neighboring castle,
which was amazing.
But the first house, I
was alone in this house
and I'd go to bed at
night and I'd hear like
(scratching noises)
And I was like, what's that sound?
It must be birds on the
roof or something like that.
- Like a Snow White moment.
- Or something, yeah, something.
Turns out I called the -
- Little mice, making you a dress.
- Yeah, yeah, basically.
(laughing) Making me my dress.
And I called man who owned the place,
and I was like, hey, you
know, what's on the roof?
And he's like, oh yeah, the
house is haunted (laughing).
I was like, I'm sorry, what?
- [Kelly] Wait, what?
- And he said, yeah, well,
but don't worry, it's a dog.
And I was like, oh, that
makes it so much better
to have it be a dog.
And I was like, okay, well
I'm glad it's a friendly dog
but I'm not gonna stay here anymore.
I had to move because I
started getting all my mind-
- I love how he tried to make that normal.
- I know. And then when I
looked around the house,
I realized that all the
pictures were little, this dog.
And there was like dog
mugs and dog magnets
and this little Scotty dog.
And I was like, yeah, you know what?
I don't wanna do this.
- Do they keep the pictures
around to not anger it?
- [Brooke] I guess. It was a happy dog.
I mean there, it wasn't
like menacing or anything,
but definitely.
So then I moved to the carriage
house of an actual castle.
Which was, oh, I pretended-
- Even more haunted. No, I'm sure-
- It sounds so romantic,
like the best movie ever.
- I pretended I was an Outlander.
- Ah, yeah, exactly.
- I was drinking whiskey and
wrapping myself in blankets.
- [Kelly] Oh, I love that.
- And every Friday, the guys
would, those transpo guys,
would come to the set in kilts.
- Oh my gosh, that's attractive.
- And they're these
unbelievably tough, great guys.
- [Kelly] Oh, okay.
- And they were in these skirts
and you're like, this works.
- [Kelly] You really are on Outlander.
- [Brooke] You really, oh yeah.
I'm like, is it true, under?
- Is it true? Is it just, yep.
- Is it true, Brooke?
- Some of them it was,
yeah, not all of them.
I guess it's up to your discretion.